Let's look at the solution for
our test and atomic-op quiz using load
links to our conditional instructions.
So we said that the first to
instructions of the new test and
atomic op approach are the same.
Put 1 in R1 and
then load from Lockvar to R2.
The idea of test and
atomic-op is not to try the right
until we see that the lock is free.
So before trying the store we should
check whether the lock is free.
That is done by using
the B instruction here.
So the correct answer should
have been just B here.
And I'm going to write it out
to show you how it works.
So [INAUDIBLE] is that if we load
a busy value, meaning a value of 1,
then R2 is not equal to 0 and
we're just going to repeat this.
So, as long as the lock is busy,
we just keep doing the load link.
The load link without the corresponding
store conditional behaves just like
a normal load.
Yes, it's setting the link register
every time, but we're not checking it so
it's just the same as if we didn't.
But things get more interesting
once we actually see
an available value of the lock.
Then we try to do a store conditional.
So now we should use the A instruction.
So we have seen that the lock is free.
Now we try to get it.
And after this we need to check
using instruction C whether
we actually got it.
So if R1 is equal to 0, that means that
our store conditional didn't succeed.
We go back to trying to
acquire the lock again.
So we have seen that the lock is
free but between our load link and
our store conditional somebody else
managed to write to the log so
we need to retry the whole thing.
So after our load link we check
whether the log was free.
If so, we try to store conditional.
If we succeed, then we got the lock.
So the waiting for the lock to become
free is done using the same load link
that will be part of
our atomic operation
once we add the store conditional
when we see that the lock is free.